استنكر المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه
ماجد الانصاري التصريحات المنسوبه لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو في
تقارير اعلاميه بشان الوساطه القطريه
ووصفها بغير المسؤوله والمعر لجهود انقاذ
الارواح وان كانت غير مفاجئه وقال
الانصاري انه انه اذا تبين ان التصريحات
صحيحه فان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي عر
جهود الوساطه لاسباب سياسيه ضيقه بدلا من
اعطاء الاولويه لانقاذ الارواح مضيفا انه
وبدل الانشغال بعلاقه قطر الاستراتيجيه مع
الولايات المتحده على نتنياهو ان ينشغل
بتذليل العقبات امام التوصل الى اتفاق
لاطلاق سراح الرهائن وكانت القناه الثانيه
عش الاسرائيليه قد كشفت عن تسجيل مسرب
لنتنياهو خلال لقائه عائلات الاسرى في غزه
قال فيه ان قطر اكثر اشكاليه من الامم
المتحده والصليب الاحمر وبان لديه خيبه
امل من ان واشنطن لا تمارس المزيد من
الضغوط على الدوحه وبحسب التسجيل المسرف
فان نتنياهو اشار الى انه لم يشكر قطر
علنا لانها يمكن ان تمارس المزيد من الضغط
على حركه
حماس